Welcome back to the The David Pakman
Show, so CNBC has this host, Joe Kernan,
who's been around a very, very long time.
We've talked about him before. He's previously
attacked me on Twitter and he sometimes will
do really cringe interviews on CNBC, some of
which we've covered in the past. And the last
few days were no exception to that. Joe Kernan
invited on an independent energy consultant named
Alison Silverstein to talk about what happened
in Texas with the storms and the power outage.
And it sort of seemed like Joe Kernan was being
moderately reasonable during the first part
of the interview. But when Alison Silverstein
starts to assert her expertize in a way that Joe
Kernan doesn't like for political reasons, like,
for example, saying even if we continue switching
over to renewable energy, to green power,
a weakened can winterize, it can be resilient, it
can work fine and all sorts of different, whether
it started going downhill slowly, slowly, slowly.
You see the frustration build for Joe Kernan,
where at the end he ends up doing almost
like the full, prototypical, unhinged,
flat out climate science denial. Bury your head
in the sand type stuff. So we'll build to that.
We're going to pick it up where Alison Silverstein
is explaining that the reason the grid lost power
generation capacity was because, as we've now
talked about many times, talked about it last
week, talked about it earlier today, Texas opted
not to winterize many elements of their electrical
grid, including coal, natural gas and nuclear
plants and, yes, some wind turbines, despite the
fact that they were advised to winterize a decade
ago when they had similar power outages caused by
cold weather. And Allison Silverstein also
criticizes the isolated nature of Texas
grid. And so let's start there so that we're
all on the same page as to how this started
going in this bad direction for Joe Kernan.
There was all of this happened because of
insufficient power plant winterization. This was
a guideline. It wasn't mandatory. There was a huge
chunk of the natural gas supply for Texas power
plants that froze up both at the wellhead level,
at production and in pipelines. Gas plants
couldn't get the fuel that they needed to run
or cut under forecast customer demand by 20
percent, which means that they didn't have enough
generation ready to serve customer demands. That
kept rising as the night got colder and colder
and last year cut to standalone grid. So they were
unable to alleviate these shortages by importing
electricity from outside from the rest of
Texas. And that's a wonderful idea, if you
like, avoiding federal regulations. But it's a
terrible idea if you like protecting reliability
against disasters like this.
So that's sort of sets up her view.
And in the second part of this interview, it
starts to go downhill even after Joe Kernan
initially concedes that those initial critiques
of wind power and frozen windmills weren't true,
Alison Silverstein makes clear that, listen, big
picture, even if we switch over more and more to
renewable energy, it can be fine in the winter.
It's OK. And that's how it starts to get wacky.
Well, you pointed out that I forget what type
of energy you call it, but the more conventional
energy, natural gas and others that you talked
about did were affected by the coal, just like,
you know, we're, you know, initially certain
people, maybe the governor, maybe, you know,
people that that aren't big aren't big green.
New Deal proponents said, well, you know,
the windmills froze and the sun went down or
went away. So you didn't have solar or wind.
That wasn't true. But because we now know that
the conventional stuff was affected by the cold
as well. But what about renewables and the future
that we're looking at? Will. Will we be ready for
adverse weather events if we're if we're much more
dependent on this this new age, renewable energy?
Of course we will. And the thing is, what
grid reliability requires that you understand
the resources that you have.
So Joe starts to get a look of
on his face because Alison Silverstein says,
of course, we will be ready for weather events
under a renewable energy system and then by
the end of it, it's full on climate denialism
with Joe Kernan repeating some of these silly
things. Oh, they said it was going to get warmer,
but the warmer can make it cooler and none of it
makes sense. And it's all just silly. Take a look.
And we can make a grid much more
stable with more efficiency.
But I mean, there have been cold spells before
in Texas. This was similar to one of what at
how long ago was it? About 30, 2011. Right.
I mean, it's 2011 and 1990, 1990 as well. So,
you know, I mean, it's a big leap. In the last
year, we implement all of the lessons like we
used to just be cold air from the Arctic. Now it's
a polar vortex caused by the warming. So I need to
see this. I need to see the peer reviewed science
on the on the warming causing the cold anyway.
So the point is that every time is getting
worse. Right. And and so we need to plan.
We need to plan a system that sits much
more kinds of really horrible weather.
And part of part of improving reliability in
the system is more transmission. Thank you. OK,
thank you, Alison. We appreciate it.
So the takeaway here is that anything
short of total, absolute simplicity in the eyes
of a committed climate denier means that they can
just write off the entire thing as completely
untrue. And of course, you may know and we've
been reporting on this for a decade at this point,
the climate data on this has been understood for a
very long time, many decades what was originally
sometimes called global warming, which is not
inaccurate when you talk about an increase in
global temperature, really, it's climate change
and it can include, yes, an overall warming of
the earth. It can include an overall warming of
the oceans on earth, which, by throwing off the
balance of the environment, can cause acutely hot
and cold spells in individual places over periods
of many different years. That is, understanding
how climate and weather are two different things.
But Joe Kernan either doesn't get it or doesn't
want to get it and takes any opportunity where
nuance is required to say, oh, give me a break.
It's global warming, which causes it to be
cold. Oh, it's a polar vortex. Come on, guys,
that must all just be completely fake. Climate is
the extended circumstances. Over time and place,
the whole planet might warm by two degrees, the
oceans might warm by two degrees or something,
hypothetically. And then in terms of weather, that
can cause lots of high temperature records and low
temperature records in different places, it could
be extra cold in places that are often warmer.
You could have milder summers in places
that are typically hotter. You could
have more hurricanes or tornadoes or whatever
drought. As another example. And unfortunately,
this is how much of the climate denialism system
works. Oh, you used to call it global warming,
but now it's too cold in some places. So you
change the name Checkmate Liberals. This is
the level on which they're operating. If the
oceans are warming, why is it so cold in Texas?
Checkmate, liberals. Come on. And the saddest part
of this is that that type of talking point, that
type of denialism is really well suited for the
Party of antiscience, which has decried college
education. As merely liberal indoctrination for
a decade now, and although we're making progress
over time on more and more people understanding
reality, more and more people conceding that,
yes, human activity probably does play a role in
our changing climate, it is a very slow process.
And in the meantime, people like Joe Kernan can
do a lot of damage by making the progress on
public opinion on this even slower. And that's
exactly what he is trying to do. Pathetic.
We've seen this from Joe Kernan before. No
indication he's going to stop anytime soon.